this meeting between us in warm al in
officials has been seen as the official
start on a new strategy at the us
cover with a door using the number of
migrants flotation central america
de biden the ministry special
answers region ricardo zuniga
sixth winehouse profits create legal
wise  for migrants to reach the us
akira what is there white impressa
has new tracks is crossed
responds if the people separate lee and the
efforts of the wat how to create a legal
means for migration
so that people arrange to your head to use
and tank fails
who  also want to make sure that they
always and means wat accessing
protection for people who require that
protection
i am process since the storm so within
germanic increase in the number of
people being central brands and more
often than not to death nation is the
united states
la  smartboard and won hanger the scene that
was home in my friends forever found
in all the us mexico border
a man than merely nineteen tables  in
unaccompanied children from central
america where dispatch be the shark
is manfred gossip and rekker
export said something critical that now regional
integration policies be next
everything is the core chief delight of
migrants in the cylon figure and if you
enter conditions in the countries of
origin
rossel  respect die after die bring a
relationship i20 own always
to the conclusion for the no park
left and then again
years of respect in ah-kai or social
start-up change and the w of the us
administration must going to relate to be
scampi's  how you aspect that morality
operations for cooperation with sure
that she's going to be a great people
do not for chairlift mount
us the us government immigration
strategy inclusive for trillion dollars
in one sale all hunter is in el
salvador and region of central america
now  is the nordic fire
legal and service city biden
administration' something to insure the way
is actually use for its intended service
have also  or via bikenet family what this
region with new black president it
was all kinds of finance a small for
the necessary final
baris asus that this one for trillion dollars
will end up in a nice or the cyclops
president of the node and trial
much mini on which less return  on a
beautiful multi level of largest
international migration policy
experts lived probuild lions extreme
poverty and corruption
one piece al donor monument rapallo el
quseir
mexico city